[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france sans surprise le
discours à na donald trump déjà en
campagne
sans surprise le discours d'un président
déjà en campagne pour la prochaine
présidentielle
ja c'est effectivement à bien des titres
c'était un discours de campagne c'était
le type de discours qu'on s'attend à
entendre le président s'est présenté à
exposer tous ses succès au cours des
trois dernières années il a expliqué que
lorsqu'il a eu lorsqu'il est entré en
fonction il ya trois ans il avait un
plan très clair pour changer la
trajectoire des états unis en termes
notamment d'économie et il a fait le
bilan de ses succès et effectivement il
avait beaucoup de choses quand tu
pouvais parler on pourrait effectivement
se demander si il a eu autant de succès
que prévu
par exemple l'alena ou la corde avec la
chine mais quel que soit son taux de
succès effectivement il a fait des
promesses et les a tenus voilà ce qu'il
disait comment a été perçue justement
outre atlantique chez vous aux états
unis ce discours du président trump
comme toujours aux états unis
il y à vraiment deux camps cela dépendra
des sentiments des personnes vis-à-vis
de leur parti les conservateurs ont
adoré ce discours ils ont dit qu'il
s'agissait de mettre les états unis en
première ligne de parler des succès
économiques et vis à vis du chômage du
président le taux de chômage le plus bas
de notre histoire pour que ce soit pour
les hispaniques ou d'autres minorités
plus de femmes sont entrées sur le
marché du travail que depuis des
décennies il ya beaucoup de nouveaux
travailleurs notamment des femmes donc
le président a beaucoup davantage à
mettre en avant les démocrates eux
puisque le président profère des
mensonges que l'économie n'est pas au
profit de tout le monde puisque
effectivement où wall street se porte
bien les marchés poursuit aussi mais que
les américains normaux souffre cependant
les indépendants les nains affiliés en
majorité ont bien reçu ce discours c'est
sans doute le meilleur discours du
président depuis son entrée en fonction
vous l'avez dit ben soit clairement deux
camps a fait divisée
aux états unis on l'a vu d'ailleurs en
images avec cette scène un peu
surréaliste où on a un donald trump qui
refuse de serrer la main à nancy pelosi
qui est le piqué au vif déchire le
discours du président
pas très démocratique tout ça comment ça
a été perçu ça aussi chez vous voir une
telle scène au congrès américain
effectivement au sein du congrès il y à
des divisions qui est très puissante et
également dans le pays effectivement le
président n'a pas serré la main bien
qu'elle ait tendu la sienne mais même
auparavant il ya eu une insulte car
lorsque nancy pelosi a annoncé le
président ce qui est son devoir
elle a annoncé le président donald trump
alors que normalement elle doit dire
c'est un honneur et un plaisir pour moi
d'introduire le président des états unis
donc il y a plus de langage d'habitude
qu'elle n'a pas utilisé effectivement il
n'a pas serré la main et elle a déchiré
le discours c
et le discours qui a attiré le plus
attention je pense le fait qu'elle les
déchirer on a vu beaucoup d'échos
notamment sur twitter aujourd'hui donc
il ya une très forte réaction
mais cela correspond aux divisions entre
les deux pays les républicains scolaire
les démocrates sont d'accord les
démocrates
évidemment un petit peu embêté parce
qu'il ya eu ce caucus dans l'iowa dont
on va pas reparler
maintenant il ya le procès en
destitution le verdict va être donné
tout à l'heure avec probablement
évidemment et un équipement de donald
trump qu'est ce que vous gagnez les
démocrates de cette séance quels vont
être les les conséquences notamment de
cette benchmark qui va être raté
finalement pour eux effectivement c'est
une destitution raté et nous le savions
depuis le début le président trump
n'allait allait être acquitté les
démocrates les républicains contrôlent
le sénat il leur était impossible qu'il
perde sa place
les démocrates ont eu du mal à monter
une un cas concret mais c'est tout
récent sénateurs républicains un
sénateur de l'utah mitt romney qui a pu
un temps est également un candidat
présidentiel a dit qu'il voterait pour
condamner le président tron sur
l'accusation de abus de pouvoir non pas
pour l'en travaux concrets il vaudrait
donc pour le condamner pour simplement
l'abus de pouvoir
donc c'est le seul républicain à avoir
déclaré qu'il voterait en ce sens et
cela eu beaucoup d'écho dans les médias
parce que la plupart des médias a été
frustré par le fait que personne ne veut
nous changer et maintenant on a un
certain sénateurs comme susan collins
humaine qui est dans un état qui peut
être parfois démocrate ou parfois
républicain est également un personnage
très intéressant
les démocrates pourraient se servir de
cet exemple de mitt romney on essayait
de la poussée avec ketty manche et caen
donc cette décision de métro mais qui a
décidé de voter pour une condamnation
pour a évolué au cours des semaines et
des mois à venir de façon très
intéressante
merci beaucoup bonne soit ajourné les
investigations merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur france 2 puis
washington ce soir